[Music]
president biden barely lifting a finger
to fix a nationwide baby formula
shortage parents are in a full-blown
panic over whether they can keep their
babies from starving supply is down 40
percent nationwide
instead of using the bully pulpit and
demanding action all biden could muster
was a measly closed press event the
president putting out a three-point plan
to address the crisis vowing to cut the
red tape but joe was apparently too busy
to talk directly to the american people
and as usual with his presidency it
comes too little too late
jen sack sackey spinning like crazy
appears to have contradicted herself on
when biden learned about the crisis
president biden has directed the
administration to work urgently to
ensure that infant formula is safe and
available for families across the
country this has been this is work
that's been underway for months when was
the first time the president was briefed
on the shortage i'm not going to get
into internal briefings he's been made
aware of it through the process and
there's been steps
it would have been yes
and as american families scrambled to
keep their babies fed a gop
congresswoman making a bombshell claim
cat kamik releasing photos she says she
got from border patrol that apparently
shows pallets of hard to find baby
formula ready for illegal immigrants to
use
there were several agents that actually
sent me text messages with photos and
videos of not just boxes but pallets of
unopened unused waiting to be used baby
formula and diapers and we're talking
lots of pallets and this was at the
donna processing facility as well as the
ursula processing facility i have it
from several higher ups within the
border patrol that more pallets are
expected to arrive in the next three
days
we did reach out twice to the department
of homeland security for comment but
haven't heard back
all right jesse uh i guess now we can
add the baby food uh
shortage uh to the list of other
disasters that this administration is
dealing with or maybe not dealing with
you add it to the laundry list and you
have to say to yourself is this is this
just continuously what we're going to
have to deal with without anyone really
doing anything about it yeah there's
shortages everywhere there's one in the
white house
listen biden's so old school he probably
thinks all women breastfeed anyway i'm
surprised he hasn't gone after big
formula there's a few reasons why this
is happening there's a few yeah well
that's it
there's a few reasons why there was a
baby bust during cove then there was a
baby boom post covered people started
getting busy then a lot of people are
stealing the baby food because you can
sell it for high prices on the black
market and then you have the recall you
have the supply chains and there's a
shortage of labor and cow milk cow milk
ingredients there's a shortage of in
this country in 2022 does biden see any
of this no yesterday we played a sound
bite of whoopi goldberg saying none of
this is biden's fault he walks around he
steps on a loose floor board and it hits
him in the face things keep hitting him
in the face that's because joe and the
democrats can't nail down any of the
damn floorboards everything from baby
formula to crime to inflation to gas
prices he's surprised by the man has no
vision he's like a quarterback he gets
under the center and he has no idea how
to read a defense right he's reacting to
everything you have to get out there and
anticipate things that are happening and
at this point what he's done with
families he says he cares about children
and families first she calls kids racist
in school then he calls parents domestic
terrorists then they can't feed their
babies but we can feed the ukrainian war
machine we can feed the illegal alien
babies but we can't feed our own babies
it's sad well you know doesn't it add
greg to the america last theme that has
been going on since joe biden became
president you know that if what the
congresswoman says is true and i have no
reason to doubt her that there are
pallets of baby formula i said the other
day on this show last weekend my
daughter's baby 10 months old she said
mom can you go look for baby formula two
places i went to nothing zero and now do
you know how fired up i am that they're
they've got these on pallets at the
border i mean what about our kids well
it's it's not america last it's a
specific number of americans last
permission to go off yes okay
the government doesn't like half of the
people it governs
actually it might even be higher i mean
you could it's not just trumpers and
republicans whites straits males
suburban moms this is the party for the
oppressed
and even when you're a mom with a baby
let's face it you're an oppressor right
you you reproduce which harms the
environment uh you expand your carbon
footprint with family you didn't
terminate the child
you know so there's no maybe no baby
formula they think is not a bad thing
and
jesse's right
if we had an engaged president who could
see the priorities of the the average
american clearly instead of running
cover for kind of woke policies whether
it's canceling student debt defunding
the police the medicalization of
children uh it would we would have
we would have beaten this thing or got a
head start on this instead you know we
make fun of him about losing his keys
whatever losing his place but he's kind
of lost the sense of what america is
right he has forgotten that he's
president of all of us and he is the
most slow to react president probably in
u.s history and it mirrors his own slow
to react mannerisms and then when he's
caught out he just starts yelling
right
and it's a manufactured rage i don't
know if you saw that tape yesterday it's
a manufactured rate saying like this is
my kind of action but no it's a it's a
man shouting at the clouds and really
having no idea what to do and i think
that the american public has every right
to be enraged and not the kind of rage
that burns down cities which is
acceptable to some democrats in this
case
your kids go hungry
you're going to see more than parents at
the school boards
okay haraldo you know the wall street
journal yesterday had a very interesting
article and they said that this this
recall at the manufacturing plant at
abbott in michigan is where has worsened
an already existing industry uh where
they've got a shortage of baby food but
what was stunning to me in this article
was that they the center for disease
control says that there is no connection
between anything at that michigan plant
that's been closed down since february
17th and the children who the two babies
who died and two were injured and so the
question that i have is if the cdc says
that there's no contamination uh one
person said on fox today i think it was
james freeman he said is this a
government-created shortage why don't
they just go back in and say start
producing it may be a government-created
shortage but i think that it is wrong
and unfair to minimize the fact that uh
similac and aluminum
alignment and the other
baby formulas have been recalled they
have been recalled that is a fact why
would they recall because four kids got
sick two of the kids died of these
bacterial infections
so there's several things that go on
number one
the fda was slow to react they got the
complaints about abbott labs in october
it wasn't until the end of january that
they inspected the abbott plant a
whistleblower at abbott has accused the
baby formula manufacturer of falsifying
records failing to keep records uh
releasing untested baby formula and
hiding the records from 20 when they
tested that's the issue the the it is
interesting that abbott in in regard and
uh into support of what you said about
uh the ccc uh abbott is giving a number
out that people can call
and i'll let the producers tell me
whether i should give the number uh to
get the baby formula from abbott on the
assumption that
you know it's safe enough that you
rather feed the baby than ever are you
saying that abbott will give people
formula based on a number give me the
number we'll put it up okay all right so
uh fantastic i don't know if it's okay
let the producers tell you okay but what
i want to do is i want to go to you
deacon the other thing that i found out
that i thought was very unusual is that
98
of the formula that we use in this
country for babies and by the way if
you're not familiar with this if you
don't have kids you can't just give
babies food you've got to have formula
or you can't make it apparently
we sell that formula to other countries
to ireland and other countries i mean
what do we do now do we now pull back
and say it's america first is that what
joe biden should be doing well one thing
that the fda
should have done and is planning to do
according to the talking points that
they were regurgitating today is
alleviating some of the trade
restrictions that the fda has in place
on formula why did they wait
because the shortages were going up and
up and up week after week month after
month this is not just an abbot problem
there were supply problems on formulas
months and months before
last month there was an april 10th the
week of april 10th 31 of the most
popular baby formula brands were out of
stock
uh
week of april 24th
it was up to 40 percent so jin saki has
the
gall to stand up there and say we've
known about that for months okay so you
knew about it for months and didn't do
anything and frightened these parents
and potentially let children starve
that's your america if you knew about it
for months so the fda is apparently
going to alleviate some of these trade
restrictions also there are all these
other regulations this seems to be the
broad problem for biden incorporated is
that like there's a mandate that
retailers have to wait 90 days before
marketing a new infant formula why does
that exist when there are vast shortages
in this country so and abbott there were
four babies who got sick two of whom who
died and
and they it took them they still haven't
even restarted the plant it's two weeks
from now why was the fda and the cdc and
dragging their feet about this when the
formula shortages were getting worse and
worse and that's the whole point where
there's not trust
she says oh we're tracking it who cares
if you're tracking it do something i
just want to add one more wait i just
want to add one more thing they
the the the bacterial infections were
not traced to that plant yeah purists
and
that's what we said biden
they they live in a world that doesn't
exist that they want to exist they don't
live in the real world they're trying to
recreate this like left-wing land of the
loss well you'll be able to wear oil and
gas donuts where oil and gas don't exist
and where men knocked out hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else